Am 20. Juni hat der Rechtsausschuss des Europäischen Parlaments eine Urheberrechtsreform verabschiedet, die in Netz und Medien kontrovers diskutiert wird. Ein zentraler Bestandteil dieser Reform soll Verlagen, Plattenfirmen und anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften zugutekommen. Aber es gehen handfeste Gefahren für die Freiheit des Netzes von dem Vorschlag aus. Julia Reeder sitzt als Abgeordnete für die Piratenpartei im EU-Parlament und erklärt, wo sie Probleme in der Reform sieht.
Das ist einerseits der Artikel 13 zu Upload-Filtern und andererseits der Artikel 11 mit dem sogenannten Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger. Beide diese Artikel haben zu großen Protesten geführt, weil sie das Internet in ihren Grundfunktionsweisen angreifen. Also ursprünglich das Ziel dieses Artikel 13 war, einen Streit zwischen Musikindustrie und YouTube beizulegen, dass YouTube eben für die Musik, die dort hochgeladen wird, die YouTube auch monetarisiert, die Verwertungsgesellschaften nicht entsprechend vergütet. Und das ist denke ich auch durchaus irgendwie ein berechtigtes Anliegen. Aber das Problem ist, dass dieser Artikel 13 wirklich weit über das Ziel hinaus schießt und auch absolut kontraproduktive Maßnahmen enthält, wie dieser Upload-Filter. Nach diesem Vorschlag werden so gut wie alle Online-Plattformen, wo User Inhalte hochladen und öffentlich machen können, direkt haftbar für alle Urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer Nutzer. Und sie wären zusätzlich dazu verpflichtet, Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, dass Urheberrechtsverletzungen gar nicht erst stattfinden. Das heißt mit anderen Worten, ihnen bliebe gar nichts anderes übrig, als die Installation von automatischen Filtern. Teilweise kennen wir diese Filter schon. YouTube's Content ID löscht alle nase lang legale Inhalte, weil diese Filter überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind, zu erkennen, wer tatsächlich der rechtmäßige Rechteinhaber ist. Und ob es sich vielleicht um eine legale Parodie oder ein Zitat handelt. Gerade diese Woche hat z.B. der britische Schauspieler Stephen Fry ein Video von sich selbst verlinken wollen, das dann plötzlich in Großbritannien gesperrt war.
Damit könnte sich ein Urheberrechtsschutz in eine Zensurmaschine verwandeln. Außerdem enthält der Vorschlag auch etwas, das man in Deutschland schon fast als Gescheitheit angesehen hatte. Die Wiederkehr des Leistungsschutzrechts. Und das ist keinem Deut besser geworden, erklärt Julia Rehder.
Bei Artikel 11 geht es nicht um das Hochladen von Inhalten, sondern um das Verlinken von Presseartikeln. Nach diesem Artikel würde ein neues Recht für Presseverleger geschaffen, das selbst für die kleinsten Ausschnitte aus Presseartikeln gelten würde. Also Journalisten haben bereits ein Urheberrecht an ihren Artikeln. Das gilt aber nicht für ganz einfache, rein faktische Sätze, wie zum Beispiel Angela Merkel trifft Theresa May. Wenn man aber im Internet einen Presseartikel verlinken will, dann muss man zumindest die Überschrift dieses Artikels irgendwie verwenden können, denn sonst wissen die User ja überhaupt nicht, was sich hinter diesem Link verbirgt. Insofern stellt dieser Vorschlag eine große Gefahr für die Informationsfreiheit dar, zumal es wirklich mildere Alternativvorschläge geht, nach denen die Verleger unmittelbar gegen tatsächliche Urheberrechtsverletzungen an Presseartikeln vorgehen könnten. Sie könnten damit auch die Presseartikel gegenüber Online-Plattformen wie zum Beispiel Facebook lizenzieren, ohne erst alle einzelnen Urheber um Erlaubnis fragen zu müssen. Aber was absolut gar nicht geht, ist eben so ein Leistungsschutzrecht, das selbst Inhalte schützt, die urheberrechtlich gar nicht geschützt sind.
Der Rechtsausschuss hat beide Artikel angenommen. Die Upload-Filter sind mit 13 zu 12 Stimmen denkbar knapp durchgegangen. Für das Leistungsschutzrecht gab es noch weniger Bedenkenträger. Auch wenn das im Gesetzgebungsprozess der EU ein wichtiger Schritt ist, den viele als entscheidend ansehen, muss das Gesetz noch vor das EU-Parlament. Damit gibt es noch eine weitere Möglichkeit, das Vorhaben aufzuhalten, wie Julia Rehder erklärt.
Wenn die Abgeordneten in dieser Abstimmung dem Ausschussmandat zustimmen, dann können sofort Verhandlungen mit dem Rat über diese Richtlinie beginnen. Leider hat auch der Rat, also die nationalen Regierungen, dem Leistungsschutzrecht und den Upload-Filtern zugestimmt. Das heißt, dann gibt es kaum noch eine Möglichkeit, das Ganze zu stoppen. Wenn aber die Mehrheit im Plenum mit Nein stimmt, dann haben wir die Möglichkeit, noch mal neue Änderungsanträge einzureichen und die schädlichsten Teile dieser Urheberrechtsreform zu entfernen. Deshalb ist es ganz wichtig, dass alle jetzt ihre Abgeordneten zu dieser Abstimmung am 4. und 5. Juli aufrufen, dort mit Nein zu stimmen. Denn viele Abgeordnete, die nicht im Rechtsausschuss sitzen, haben sich in der Vergangenheit gar nicht so intensiv mit dem Thema Urheberrecht beschäftigt. Und auf den ersten Blick sieht das vielleicht erst mal vernünftig aus, dass man sagt, man möchte Urheber im Netz besser schützen. Aber Fakt ist, dass diese Vorschläge von Menschenrechtsaktivisten, von Wissenschaftlern usw. wirklich massiv kritisiert werden. Und sie letzten Endes eher zum Aufbau einer Zensurinfrastruktur führen, als dass tatsächlich Urheberinnen und Urheber damit größere Einnahmen erwarten können.
Falls ihr also noch helfen wollt, Uploadfilter und Leistungsschutzrecht zu stoppen, kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten. Wie das genau geht, wird auf saviourinternet.eu beschrieben.
Ihr wisst also, was ihr zu tun habt. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zur zweiten Hälfte des Chaosradios 247 mit Stefan Höfelbrink, Jörg Friedrich und Johannes Christmann. Hallo. Hallo. Wir haben euch in der ersten halben Stunde ausführlich vorstellen lassen, also wir wissen jetzt, wer ihr seid, was ihr macht und wo ihr herkommt. Und das gemeinsame Ding, weswegen ihr aber auch heute hier seid, ist ja der Saftladen Berlin. Wir haben schon irgendwie gehört, das nennt es ein Gaming-Kollektiv, es ist euer Arbeitsplatz, ihr arbeitet da zusammen. Aber jetzt noch mal ganz genau erklärt, was ist eigentlich der Saftladen? Also was ist die Idee dahinter? Warum seid ihr darauf gekommen, das genau so zu machen, wie es funktioniert, außer dass ihr nicht mehr in Riads Wohnzimmer sitzen wolltet, in Unterhosen?
Schlecht war es nicht. Also da stecken viele Sachen dahinter. Ich denke mal, grundlegendste Idee ist, dass wir daran glauben, dass, wenn man gemeinsam zusammensitzt und auch mal den Blick auf andere Projekte, andere kreative Schaffenswerke und Auseinandersetzungen richten kann, hilft einem das selber auch ganz viel, dass man mal so ein bisschen rauskommt aus seiner Denke. Außerdem hatte das eben, das habe ich schon vorhin kurz erwähnt, haben wir gesehen, dass das in der Berliner Szene, die eigentlich recht stark ist, was so die unabhängige Spieleentwicklung angeht, fehlte das. Da gab es ganz viele Events, wo man temporär zusammen kam und sich ausgetauschen konnte, aber danach gingen alle wieder nach Hause und man hatte nie so einen Anlaufpunkt, wo man hingehen kann, wo man weiß, da trifft man immer jemanden an. Oder wenn Leute die Stadt besucht haben, dass die auf einen Schlag irgendwie mal mehrere Spieleentwickler aus einem unabhängigen Bereich treffen konnten.
Aber vielleicht jetzt mal, was ist denn das genau? Ihr nennt das Kollektiv, als wir den Sendungsteaser geschrieben haben, hatten wir zuerst das Wort Co-Working Space. Das stimmt ja nicht. Da kann ja nicht jeder einfach kommen und einen Tisch mieten.
Theoretisch funktioniert es wie ein Co-Working Space.
Und praktisch, was ist also der Unterschied?
Praktisch ist der Unterschied der größte, dass wir eigentlich permanent ausgebucht sind und keine Leute annehmen können, weil wir nicht genug Platz haben. Außerdem gehen die Leute nicht einen Monat rein und dann wieder raus oder so. Und wir müssen leider auch einen Auswahlprozess machen, wen wir in den Saftladen mit reinnehmen. Insofern ist es schon so ein bisschen eher ein kuratierter Co-Working Space.
Ich würde den Unterschied vielleicht zwischen Standard Co-Working Space ist ein bisschen wie Airbnb zu einer WG. Also in der WG suchst du dir ja aus, wer da mit reinkommt. Man hat, also es gibt ja so totale Zweck-WGs, aber in den meisten WGs hat man da noch ein bisschen was miteinander zu tun und kocht vielleicht mal zusammen. Und es ist halt eben auch eine Gemeinschaft und nicht nur, nicht nur ich habe hier das Zimmer gemietet.
Könntest du mal wieder abspülen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich habe doch erst.
Was sind zum Beispiel die Kriterien? Also wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt nur bestimmte Leute da haben oder ihr sucht das schon aus, nach welchen Kriterien wird denn da kuratiert? Das klingt total nett übrigens, kuratieren, wenn es um Leute geht.
Das ist situationsabhängig. So ein bisschen. Also jetzt momentan zum Beispiel eigentlich nur noch Menschen, die uns mit unserer Diversitätsquote helfen zum Beispiel. Also wir hatten jetzt gerade erst überlegt, ob wir eine Gruppe von drei Entwicklern mit reinnehmen. Es waren aber auch alles drei Kerle und dann haben wir gesagt, ne sorry. Also wir sind sowieso voll. Wir hätten vielleicht noch Platz machen können, aber wie wir eingangs schon erwähnt haben, wir haben so ein bisschen immer noch die Problematik, dass es halt hauptsächlich weiße Männer sind, die an Spielen arbeiten oder auch im Saftladen bei uns zumindest sind. Ein paar Frauen haben wir, aber das ist noch nicht genug. Insofern, das ist zum Beispiel für uns momentan die Hauptauswahl. Ansonsten geht's grob darum.
Aber schon auf jeden Fall Spieleentwicklerinnen. Ja, grob.
Also müssen nicht unbedingt alle Spieleentwickler sein. Also wir haben auch Leute, die jetzt nicht direkt an Spielen arbeiten. Zum Beispiel Lorenzo Pilia, das ist ein Italiener, der hier in Berlin lebt und arbeitet. Der ist eher tätig im Bereich Eventmanagement und der ist zum Beispiel bei der Amaze, der Programmdirektor. Oder ist der Organisator von Talk and Play, das ist ein super wichtiges Community-Event für Spiele-Machende hier in Berlin. Aber selber macht er eigentlich nicht hauptsächlich Spiele.
Aber alle, die da sind, haben schon was mit Spielen zu tun?
Die haben schon im Ferntesten mindestens was mit Spielen zu tun, ja.
Und das heißt, wenn man reingeht in den Saftladen, dann ist das tatsächlich wie in der WG, man zieht da ein für unbestimmte Zeit und nicht auf den Monat.
Man sollte nicht da schlafen. Auch wenn das Jörg Reisig oft macht, lieber Jörg. Apropos, wenn das weiter so geht, müssen wir die Gebühren für dich erhöhen. Aber eigentlich schläft man nicht da.
Das ist auch ein Problem, das man auch aus Hacker Spaces kennt. Der Saftladen ist ein Ort, in dem man langfristig zusammenarbeitet. Wie ist das konkret? Wir müssen uns das eigentlich vorstellen. Hacker Space, also hier in Berlin, der Club ist, wenn jetzt nicht gerade Chaosradio ist, wo tatsächlich drei Stuhlreihen vor einem Sofa stehen, ist ja, war salopp gesagt, ein großer Tisch, wo man rumsitzen kann und ein paar Sofas, die so ein bisschen noch rumschieben, wo man auch draufsitzen kann. Was ist der Saftladen?
Ein großer Raum, den man Tisch haben kann, wenn man möchte. Ansonsten bringt man ihn selber mit, das ist auch möglich. Also es sind vor allen Dingen Arbeitsplätze.
Also es ist eher Büroatmosphäre als jetzt so eine loungeige, wie hier, würde ich sagen.
Wie ist das, weil du auch gerade gesagt hast, das soll ja auch Anlaufpunkt sein, wenn man in der Stadt ist, aus der Szene kommt und mal sozusagen Leute treffen will. Es gibt hier beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin, gibt es zum Beispiel einen offenen Donnerstag, da kann man einfach sozusagen, wenn man sich auch nur am ran interessiert und nur mal gucken will, wie das aussieht, kann man einfach kommen. Gibt es auch was beim Saftladen auch, dass ihr sagt, man kann bei uns eigentlich immer vorbeikommen, mal gucken, wo muss man sich da anmelden oder macht ihr sowas gar nicht. Gibt ihr, keine Ahnung, zweimal im Jahr so ein Event oder?
Also dadurch, dass schon die Leute auch wirklich konzentriert arbeiten, ist es schon auch eher so, dass wir vorher mal Kontakt aufnehmen haben sollten. Also wir haben alle zwei Wochen zum Beispiel machen wir den Social Club, nennen wir das. Das ist ein, wo wir zusammenkommen, zum Beispiel morgen wieder, jeden zweiten Freitag. Da sitzen wir dann ab sechs rum und unterhalten uns, machen so ein bisschen Stuhlkreis, hat so ein bisschen was von einer Selbsthilfegruppe für Spieleentwickler.
Trage ich Hosen oder nicht?
Genau, trage ich Hosen oder nicht. Was für Spiele habe ich in meiner Jugend gespielt? Nein, aber da erzählen wir so ein bisschen auch, was uns umtreibt, auch außerhalb vom Spiele machen. Weil wir einfach auch wollen, wir wollen mehr über die Menschen erfahren und wollen über einfach nur ein gemeinsames Nebeneinander herarbeiten, uns auch kennenlernen. Und da kann man auch gut vorbeikommen und da haben wir oft auch Gäste zum Beispiel. Aber auch hier mit uns Kontakt aufnehmen. Man kann immer jederzeit saftladen.berlin auf die Webseite gehen und da gibt es ein Kontaktformular oder ihr könnt uns direkt anschreiben. Und da machen wir gerne was mit jedem aus. Also wir haben immer wieder gerne Gäste und lernen gerne neue Leute kennen.
Und gibt es irgendwie so, wie soll man sagen, Zukunftsplanung oder sowas? Das hört sich für mich an, also wir brauchen einen Ort und der Ort soll uns eine Arbeitatmosphäre bieten und es möglich machen, mit anderen gleichgesinnten Menschen zusammenzuarbeiten. Und wenn sich das so ein bisschen trägt, dann ist das okay. Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, bei deinem Spiel kannst du nie loslassen, du musst immer weiter feilen. Ist der Saftladen jetzt was, wo du denkst oder wo ihr denkt, das ist super, ich habe so einen Platz zum Arbeiten und der ist auch eher wie eine nette WG und nicht sozusagen wie so ein Bürokäfig. Ist es das jetzt oder soll das so ein Spiele-Hub Berlin werden, die Indie-Manage?
Ja, da muss man vorsichtig sein. Das Spiele-Hub geht dann gleich los mit Inkubatoren und so ein Kram und da tun wir uns so ein bisschen schwierig. Also wir wollen ja schon auch aufpassen, dass die Seele bleibt und dass das beibehält, was das eigentlich ausmacht. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich ist der Wunsch da, dass da mehr draus wird, dass wir momentan eine Momentaufnahme haben auf einem Weg, wo wir mittelfristig vielleicht so ein paar Ideen haben, aber langfristig nicht wirklich wissen, wo es hingeht. Also es passieren auf jeden Fall immer mehr Dinge gemeinschaftlich. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel die ersten Workshops gemeinsam gemacht, hier einmal einer BTK, eine ganze Woche lang zusammen mit… Genau, eine Fachhochschule hier in Berlin.
Also nicht für euch, sondern für Studenten.
Für Studenten haben wir einen Workshop gestaltet. Da ist der Jongor, der ist dort ein Professor, auf uns zugekommen hat, hat gemeint, hey, wollen wir nicht mal eine Woche lang Saftladen-Workshop machen? Und dann haben wir hier Stefan zum Beispiel auch, verschiedene Leute aus dem Saftladen zu verschiedenen Themen eine ganze Woche lang Unterricht dort gegeben, aber bunt gemischt. Aber es war halt alles so ein bisschen eingefärbt durch Saftladen. Es hatte schon so einen Grundtenor, hauptsächlich die Independent Games und meistens so ein bisschen unabhängig kleine Ansätze an verschiedenste Themenbereiche, die irgendwie meistens wieder mit Spielen zu tun hatten. Oder dass wir zusammen Gamejams machen. Es sind auch schon Spiele entstanden, die halt einfach eine Kollaboration waren aus verschiedenen verschiedenen Studios, das ist jetzt nicht so häufig. Auch keins von diesen Spielen ist jetzt irgendwie groß kommerziell geworden, außer eins, was in Kanada ein erfolgreiches Hockeyspiel geworden ist. Aber ne, also das wächst noch und da haben wir auch schon Ideen und viele Perspektiven. Das Problem, an das wir immer geraten, ist halt ein räumliches Problem. Wir sind jetzt schon wieder ausgebucht. Jetzt schon haben sozusagen Firmen, die bei uns drinsitzen, ein Problem mit Wachstum. Wenn wir jetzt noch mehr Leute haben wollen, zum Beispiel Maschinenmensch, wir wollen jetzt demnächst wachsen. Was wir dann machen müssen, ist jetzt gucken, wer geht aus dem Saftladen vielleicht mal raus mittelfristig, langfristig, verlassen dann doch ab und zu mal Leute den Laden. Und da müssen wir gleich den Finger drauf halten und sagen, wir können jetzt keine neuen reinnehmen, weil wir brauchen jetzt wieder Plätze für wahrscheinlich Angestellte, die wir jetzt zum Beispiel erst bekommen.
Seid ihr alles so ein, zwei, drei Mann Teams, oder gibt es auch größere oder kleiner? Geht ja gar nicht.
Also die größte Firma ist Studio Firsbin. Die haben glaube ich zehn Menschen, direkt gefolgt von Maschinenmensch mit vier. Und dann geht es hier so zwei Teams und dann viele Einzelleute.
Wie ist das denn eigentlich mit dem Geld? Also bei Hackspace ist es ja häufig so, da wird ein Verein gegründet oder sowas, dann zahlen da sehr viele Leute irgendwie Mitgliedsbeiträge, dann kriegt man das irgendwie so geregelt. Wie ist das bei euch? Gibt es da einfach sozusagen einen Preis für einen Arbeitsplatz, muss ich da zahlen? Oder habt ihr auch so eine soziale Komponente, dass ihr sagt, okay Einzelkämpfer, dem es gerade nicht so gut geht, muss vielleicht weniger zahlen? Oder ist das da eine Grenze, wo ihr sagt Business, oder ist das auch so, dass man da das anders macht?
Also, die Sache ist die Studio Fisbin und meine Firma Maschinenmensch. Wir haben einfach einen Mietvertrag mit der GSG. Das ist die Hausverwaltung, wo wir unser Büro haben. Und wir tragen diese Kosten und wir vermieten das dann unter an die jeweiligen Personen. Sprich, wir können jetzt nicht den Tisch umsonst hergeben, weil dann müssen wir das extra tragen. Die Rechnung war schon so anfangs gemacht, dass wir sozusagen gestrichen da rauskommen, keiner legt drauf, alle zahlen irgendwie ähnlich viel und wir haben alle den gemeinsamen Vorteil des Zusammensetzens. Was natürlich auch für die Firmen ein relativ großes Risiko ist. Also erstens mal mussten wir Kautionen bezahlen und wenn jetzt Ausfälle sind, also jetzt mal total verrückt, nächsten Monat auf einmal steigen alle aus oder so und dann sitzen wir da und müssen Miete zahlen und können das eigentlich nicht. Also wir gefährden eigentlich unsere Firma in einem Feld, was komplett fremd ist von normalerweise gehen independent Spielefirmen ja an anderen Sachen, Bankrott und nicht an irgendwelchen Fehlenden.
Dann ist es gescheitert, alle sind ausgezogen.
Also schon auch ein Risiko für uns und das tragen wir auch komplett alleine. Hätte man Hosen tragen sollen, aber das ist auch keine Lösung.
Nee, Hosen tragen ist definitiv keine Lösung. Also Kindern frühzeitig Zugang zur Technik geben und keine Hosen tragen. Wir kriegen noch so eine Liste zusammen heute an den wirklich wichtigen Dingen, die für das Game Design wichtig sind. Ich möchte mal ein bisschen beim Geld bleiben und vom Saftladen wieder einen Schritt weggehen, weil das muss ja tatsächlich irgendwo herkommen. Wir haben von Stefan am Anfang schon gehört, da geht man sozusagen in Vorleistung. Aber hast du eine Idee, also andersherum gefragt, du arbeitest an einem Spiel Death Trash. Und bist du jetzt seit drei Jahren und dann sozusagen kommst du in eineinhalb Jahren vielleicht raus. Ist da die Hoffnung, dass es sozusagen so ein Riesenhit wird, dass es die letzten fünf Jahre kompensiert? Oder wie finanziert man sich als Spieleentwickler?
Also, ich bin da wirklich noch so mittendrin und ich hab's halt bis jetzt noch nicht geschafft, so das zu finanzieren.
Aber es war von Anfang an so der Gedanke da oder man hat schon erkannt, das Spiel ist irgendwie, das trifft auf Interesse.
Deswegen war das halt so immer schon die Idee, vielleicht mach ich ein Crowdfunding damit und darauf dann die ganze Zeit hingearbeitet. Aber man ist auch die ganze Zeit mit einigen Publishern im Gespräch.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Publisher, die sich für solche Projekte interessieren. Vielleicht könnt ihr das auch sagen, aber kannst du erst mal erläutern, für die Leute, die gar nicht wissen, was das heißt, was bedeutet das denn, wenn man mit einem Publisher in einen Vertrag abschließt? Gibt der einem dann vorher Geld, damit man das Spiel fertig macht? Oder sagt der nur, wenn du es fertig hast, kümmern wir uns ums Marketing? Oder was genau passiert da eigentlich?
Ich glaube, da gibt es die verschiedensten Abmachungen und Verträge.
Aber recht häufig, zumindest früher war es sehr häufig so, dass der Publisher die Entwicklung bezahlt. Und sobald das Spiel rauskommt, kriegen halt beide Parteien ihren bestimmten Prozentsatz.
Okay, dann wird der Publisher wahrscheinlich erst mal gucken, dass der seine Ausgaben wieder reinkriegt.
Genau, das ist auch sehr häufig, dass der erst mal seine Ausgaben wieder reinholt und danach von dem Reingewinnen dann zieht er dann auch seine Prozente.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, Crowdfunding ist so eine Überlegung. Ist das mittlerweile ein Standardweg, sein Spiel zu finanzieren? Oder ist das so ein bisschen wie Glottospielen? Also ich kann mir das schwer vorstellen, weil von außen hört man ja eigentlich immer nur von den Spielen, die irgendwann rauskommen, wo gesagt, ja, das war übrigens dieser Crowdfunding-Erfolg, der damals irgendwie eigentlich nur 50.000 Dollar wollte, aber vier Millionen bekommen hat und jetzt 20 Jahre entwickelt wurde. Trag ich mich zu sagen, ist das die Regel? Man geht halt Crowdfunding und dann wird das halt finanziert? Oder ist es eher so, naja, also das kann man probieren, aber es ist eher auch so, kann ich mir auch ein Lotto-Ticket kaufen?
Na, also man kann nicht alles mit Sicherheit sagen, aber oft kann man schon so ein bisschen einschätzen, könnte das ungefähr eine bestimmte Anzahl an Leuten schon interessieren, dass die dann direkt jetzt schon Geld dafür eher geben. Also Stefan würde wahrscheinlich vier Millionen bekommen.
Wie machst du das eigentlich so? Hast du dieses Spiel, gibt es da schon sozusagen so eine Art Beta-Version, die man irgendwie ausprobieren kann? Oder woher weißt du, dass es auf Interesse stößt? Hast du einen YouTube-Trailer, der 50 Millionen Klicks bekommen hat?
Nein, leider nicht. Nein, also ich war von Tag eins an mit dem Spiel online, auf Twitter zum Beispiel. Also als ich noch gar nicht wusste, dass es jetzt mein Spiel werden wird, habe ich einfach schon die Grafiken, an denen ich gearbeitet habe, immer von Tag eins an hochgeladen.
Und alles davor verblasst auf einmal gegen die Zahlen, die ich damit bekommen habe. Und dann wusste man, da ist irgendwas.
Twitter Celebrity.
Aber Leute, Twitter ist doch zu was gut.
Ja, natürlich, von Spielen auf jeden Fall. Ja, und dann über die drei Jahre jetzt natürlich so ein bisschen angesammelt, auch ein Publikum.
So dass ich mir denke, wenn ich jetzt ein Quad-Fanling versuchen würde, wird es zumindest so eine bestimmte Menge. Ja, okay, also du würdest nicht bei null anfangen? Jörg, wo kriegt ihr, ihr habt ja dieses Spiel, man arbeitet da nicht mit Spiel, woher kommt das Geld?
Also wir sind glücklicherweise vom Medienboard Berlin-Brandenburg gefördert worden. Das ist eine Wirtschaftsförderung, das heißt, das ist eigentlich ein Kredit, den wir aber nur im Erfolgsfall zurückzahlen müssen. Wie praktisch.
Es ist ein bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen, um genau zu sagen.
Es ist ein bedingt... Es ist kein Kredit. Ich merke schon. Genau, es ist ein bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen.
Ja, richtig. Genau.
Dass man zurückzahlen muss, und zwar auch erst dann, wenn man seine eigenen Kosten wieder rein bekommen hat. Es ist aber so, dass man das nur bekommt, wenn man das gegenfinanziert. Also man bekommt sozusagen die Summe, die man selber gegenfinanziert, oder bis zu bekommt man als Darlehen.
Wie kommt man da ran? Ich meine, es ist der Wunsch, wenn man sich den Spieleentwickler als Warstel aufbaut. Man versenkt immer noch das eigene Geld, das man aufbringen musste, aber 50 Prozent vom Topf werden übernommen.
Ja, es ist total super. Man muss sich bewärmen. Es funktioniert ungefähr wie eine Filmförderung. Es gibt einen ganz kleinen Teil, ich glaube, fünf Prozent dessen, was für Filme ausgegeben wird, wird auch für Spiele ausgegeben. Das reicht ja auch. Das entspricht ja auch ungefähr dem Marktanteil, oder? Das wird sich auch nicht ändern, solange das so bleibt. Genau, das Medienboard ist sehr aktiv. Die sind tatsächlich auch auf diesen Game-Veranstaltungen. Es gibt das Talk and Play in Berlin. Das ist eine Veranstaltung alle zwei Monate. Die ist kostenlos, kann jeder hinkommen. Da gibt es einmal Talks. Indie-Entwickler aus der Umgebung stellen ihre Spiele vor. Die kann man dann spielen. Hence Talk and Play. Dort zum Beispiel ist das Medienboard auch da sehr häufig und spricht dann auch direkt Entwickler und Entwicklerinnen an und sagt so, hey, gutes Spiel habt ihr da. Bewerbt euch doch mal bei uns.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ein Erfolg. Die Chancen, dass wir unser bedingt rückzahlbares Darlehen zurückbezahlt bekommen und die Bedingungen erfüllt werden, ist relativ hoch. Oder machen die sowas auch wie, das sieht künstlerisch wertvoll aus?
Ich glaube, die wollen die Mischung. Es ist so ähnlich wie bei der Filmförderung. Die wollen Sachen, die einen gewissen Anspruch haben und interessant sind. Das ist mein Eindruck. Ich sitze ja nicht im Gremium, keine Ahnung. Ich habe das einfach nur Glück gehabt. Aber mein Eindruck ist, die möchten gerne Dinge, die interessant sind irgendwie. Und gleichzeitig aber auch, die einen gewissen wirtschaftlichen Erfolg versprechen.
80% zahlen nicht zurück, habe ich gerade neulich wieder gehört. Zurückzahlen ist die Ausnahme eher. Da achten sie zum Glück nicht so sehr drauf, dass es jetzt wirklich... Also es muss kommerziell aufgestellt sein. Leider ist es nicht wirklich so eine reine Kunstförderung. Das gibt es gar nicht, soweit ich weiß. Rein für Spiele. Also man muss schon auch so eine Absicht der Gewinnein oder der Gewinn des Gewinnes haben. Aber es ist definitiv nicht im Hauptblickfeld eine Förderentscheidung.
Okay, wir sprechen gleich noch über Maschinenmensch, die auch gefordert wurden, die die Bedingungen erfüllt haben und deswegen das Darlehen zurückgezählt haben. Wie es dazu kam, das besprechen wir gleich. Wir hören noch eine kleine Musik, die kommt auch aus dem Saftladen, aber nicht von euch, sondern die kommt aus All Walls Must Fall und ist von der Almut Schwacke, die auch schon bei euch mit ist. Der Song The Next Stop heißt er und ist wie gesagt in diesem anderen Spiel drin. Das war das aus All Walls Must Fall. Wir sind hier immer noch mit den Saftladenleuten, Johannes, Jörg und Stefan und reden jetzt, wo die Sendung fast schon wieder vorbei ist, über das Geld.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, es geht schnell, ne? Zwei Stunden sind nicht viel. Wir haben gerade darüber gelesen, wo das Geld herkommen kann und da kann man sich zum Beispiel fördern lassen und die Förderung ist kein Kredit, sondern ein, wie heißt es?
Bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen.
Ein Bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen und Maschinenmensch, ihr habt der Curious Expedition, seid da gefördert worden und Stefan, was?
Ja, darf ich noch eben einwerfen?
Ja, bitte. Also, mein Fall noch abzuschießen, ich habe mich da auch beworben, habe auch noch Zusage bekommen, aber bei mir ist das halt noch in der, es fehlt noch die Implementierung, also ich hatte den Eigenanteil noch nicht sicher.
Deswegen ist es in der Mache. Du musst den Eigenanteil noch besorgen und dann würden sie dich fördern? Ja, das wollte ich zu meinem Fall dann noch. Kann man auch so was machen, wir machen jetzt das Crowdfunding und haben dann den Eigenanteil und dann das so?
Den hatte ich in der Kalkulation mit eingerechnet, ja.
Hast du nicht hoch genug angesetzt, Stefan? Das ist das Problem, die geben einem nicht einfach nur so Geld, das ist der Haken an der Sache, sondern da muss man wirklich gegenfinanzieren, man muss, wenn man einen Antrag stellt, schon wissen, wo kommt das andere Geld her. Die geben ja maximal 50 Prozent. Also 50 Prozent von dem Geld, das man hat? Ich mache jetzt ein Spiel die nächsten zwei Jahre, das kostet mich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100.000 Euro. Dann muss ich mindestens 50.000 Euro irgendwo haben. Und zwar nicht so, die besorge ich dann, gib mir erstmal die Kohle, sondern die muss ich irgendwo haben, garantiert.
Wie habt ihr das gemacht? Wo habt ihr das Geld herbekommen?
Okay, also man muss es auch nicht unbedingt haben. Also es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die kann man machen. Also wir hatten es auch, also was wir gemacht haben, war eine Gehaltsrückstellung. Das machen die beim Film sehr häufig.
Gehabt haben werden.
Genau, sozusagen wir bezahlen uns unsere Gehälter nicht aus, solange bis wir und dieses theoretische Gehalt, was wir nicht ausbezahlt haben, bis es sich so angehäuft hat, dass das 50% hat.
Um bei dem Fall zu bleiben, ihr arbeitet solange, bis ihr 50.000 Euro verdient hättet.
Hättet, genau. Und dann schuldet uns die Firma, also mir und Riad als Angestellten, 50.000 Euro insgesamt. Und das haben wir sozusagen aufgeschrieben, dass wir das machen werden. Und dadurch hat es dann funktioniert. Unterm Strich hieß das natürlich, dass wir dann, solange wir uns kein Geld auszahlen konnten, von unserem Ersparten leben müssten. Also irgendwoher muss man immer Geld haben.
Oder jemanden, der einen durchfüttert.
Oder der einem hilft oder so. Oder Teilzeitjob oder was auch immer.
Jetzt, das will ich auch gleich noch fragen, ob es irgendwie so Brot- und Butterjobs für Spieleentwickler gibt, also klar, du kannst dann mal in der Kneipe arbeiten gehen oder irgendwas machen, was Ganze mit dem Job zu tun hat. Aber wie gesagt, kommen wir gleich zu. Erstmal noch die Frage, ihr habt das darin zurückgezahlt. Wenn ich jetzt nur die heutige Sendung rekapitle, bedeutet das, ihr habt genug getwittert. Und deswegen habt ihr euer Spiel gut verkauft. Oder wie ist das passiert?
Ja, tatsächlich haben wir Twitter sehr viel bedient. Wir haben genauso wie Stefan auch sehr aktiv über die Entwicklung berichtet. Wir haben auch viele YouTube-Videos gemacht. Über die Entwicklung und haben so ein bisschen Blick hinter die Kulissen gegeben. Und waren generell eigentlich sehr aktiv. Wir haben dieses Early Access Modell gefahren, was auf Steam ist. Sprich, wir haben unser Spiel angefangen zu verkaufen, obwohl es noch gar nicht fertig war. Und haben das ein Jahr lang gemacht.
Eine Beta-Version sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Und haben aber alle zwei Wochen eine neue Version veröffentlicht, die unseren Spielern zugänglich gemacht.
Jetzt ist ja das Internet nicht nur voller netter Leute. Fängt man sich dann nicht lauter Leute ein, die sagen, die kaufen mal ein nicht fertiges Spiel und sagen, das Spiel ist doch gar nicht fertig.
Ja, gibt's auf jeden Fall. Aber da hat eben, diese Flucht nach vorne war, glaube ich, ganz gut. Also wirklich das Zeigen, hey, guck mal, wir sind einfach nur Menschen, die dieses Spiel machen. Also, Ried und ich haben relativ früh angefangen, uns vor die Kamera zu stellen und einfach aus dem Nähkästchen zu plaudern, alle zwei Wochen immer zu den neuen Versionen. Und haben auch unsere Gesichter in die Kamera gehängt. Und haben das auch immer nicht so professionell gemacht, sondern so in einem Cut, ohne große Modifizierungen. Und ich glaube, dadurch wurde klar, hey, das sind einfach nur nette Leute, die versuchen, irgendwie das da zu reißen. Deswegen haben wir eigentlich relativ wenig diesen Hate abbekommen. Sondern die Leute haben einfach gesehen, okay, die strengen sich wirklich an, die sind dabei, die machen nicht dieses typische Early Access, wenn man da so ein bisschen drinsteckt, gibt's halt so das Klischee, die nehmen das Geld und dann hören die auf zu kommunizieren und machen die an dem Spiel weiter. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall gegen gearbeitet.
Ist es wichtig als Spieleentwickler, dass man da auch mit seiner Personality drin ist?
Ähm, nicht unbedingt. Also, das ist nicht kompatibel bei allen Menschen oder für alle Spiele. Ich fand's hilfreich. Also, es macht auf jeden Fall einen Bonus-Ding, glaube ich, wenn man das ausspielen kann, wenn man dafür gemacht ist. Kann es funktionieren, aber ist jetzt nicht eine Notwendigkeit.
Und das hat gereicht, dass sich dann genug Leute für das Spiel interessiert haben, dass es dann, als es auch gut war, gekauft wurde?
Genau, ich wollte auch noch mal sagen, es war auch, glaube ich, normal, hat auch spielerisch überzeugt.
Aber man braucht halt beides, ne? Du brauchst halt sowohl die Leute, also das muss gut sein, oder du brauchst ein richtig gutes Spiel, ne?
Also wir hatten ja nur so ein mittelmäßig gutes Spiel, aber konnten gut reden und haben es verkauft. Naja, und es wurde dann auch ein gutes Spiel, über den Zeitraum hinweg. Es sind verschiedene Konstellationen, die da funktionieren, aber in erster Linie ist es immer ganz praktisch, wenn man ein ziemlich gutes Spiel hat.
Okay, gut, klingt einleuchtend.
Willst du mich noch mal rausfragen, dass wir das Geld zurückbezahlt haben? Ansonsten würde ich noch mal gerne erzählen, dass wir so einen großen Scheck gemacht haben. Das war voll cool, wir haben so einen großen Scheck gemacht. Den hab ich von Hand gebaut. Dann wurden wir auf die Bühne gerufen und dann durften wir so einen großen Scheck übergeben. So ein Übersize, so ein Lifesize. Und es gibt das Gerücht, dass die Chefin vom Medienboard, die hat da in ihrem Büro die ganzen Wände zugekleistert mit so übergroßen Shacks. Und da hängt unsere jetzt auch angeblich.
Also jetzt Rückzahlungs-Shacks?
Der Rückzahlungs-Shack.
Von euch schon, aber an der Wand. Weil du hast ja gesagt, nur 20% zahlen zurück.
Nee, aber aus den Spielen. Aus dem innovativen audiovisuellen Inhalte, was zu keiner Kategorie von Spielen ist. Da sind es glaube ich nur 80%. Bei den anderen sind es noch weniger. Bei dem Film und so. Nein.
Aber ihr habt es geschafft. Ich wollte jetzt noch mal zurückkommen zu diesen Jobs. Wie ist es eigentlich zu sagen, wenn es gerade nicht klappt? Gibt es so Schwarzbrot-Jobs? Internetradio geht immer. Internetradio? Die Honorare hier, also die Honorare beim Chaosradio als Gast sind ja so hoch wie bei den Antifa-Demonstrationen.
Gut, das kann man ja wieder ein Jahr entwickeln.
Nein, aber ehrlich gesagt, gibt es so Dinge, die man nebenbei macht, also die ihr macht oder wo ihr Saftladen-Kollegen und Kolleginnen beobachtet, wo man häufiger mal sieht, okay, das sind anscheinend so Dinge, die kann man als Spieleentwickler sehr gut nebenbei machen?
Also ja, ja, sehr gut, ist schwierig, glaube ich. Also bei mir ist es einfach, ich doziere nebenbei und das habe ich das letzte Jahr über, als ich eben noch kein Geld hatte vom Medienbord, relativ viel gemacht. Das hat die Miete bezahlt. Und Grafiker haben relativ häufig so Freelance-Jobs entweder bei Spielen oder jetzt seit einiger Zeit gibt es ja viele Filmfirmen, die auch noch so VR-Kram produzieren. Oder so Effektfirmen gibt es ja einige in Berlin. Und die dann ganz froh sind über Leute, die sich mit sowas auskennen. Das sind so Brot-Jobs.
Das ist natürlich schwierig. Also Auftragsarbeiten muss man aber auch aufpassen, weil die dann oft teilweise, muss man Geld hinterherrennen, typische Freelancer-Problematik. Und man verwendet dann seine Zeit darauf, diese Auftragsarbeiten zu machen. Und wann macht man dann das Spiel?
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Man hört ja immer das Klischee von Leuten, die aus so großen Firmen wie ihr bei Jager kommen. Man geht da auch weg, weil es da die sogenannte Crunchtime gibt, die dann immer ist. Also dieses, man arbeitet viel, viel mehr als man eigentlich sollte. Arbeitet man dann im Saftladen weniger?
Also ich habe noch nie so wenig gearbeitet in meinem Leben wie jetzt.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
So viel Urlaub gehabt und so viel verdient.
Wie sind die anderen beiden auf dem Sofa?
Äh, nee, das kann ich von mir nicht behaupten. Aber ich meine, mein Spiel ist ja auch noch nicht draußen. Das ist dann nach, wird das dann alles super? Nee, ja, ich hoff's aber. Also es ist schon so bei mir, dass mein Ziel nicht ist, irgendwie die 60 Stunden Wochen zu ruppen. Das macht keinen Sinn und halte ich nicht für erstrebenswert. Und dann würd ich's glaub ich auch nicht machen.
Ich freu mich auf Stefan Edwards.
Aber ja, also ich muss im Moment eher mehr arbeiten, würd ich sagen, als Angestellter. Aber ich glaub ich auch normal in so ner Grundungsphase.
Stefan?
Ja, also ich hab ja auch noch nichts, was sich verkauft. Also geh ich natürlich jetzt ganz stark dann in Vorleistung. Das hat sich auch nicht verändert, glaube ich, seit der Zeit vor dem Saftladen und im Saftladen jetzt. Sag mal ein bisschen Ortswechsel. Ich mach schon sehr viele Stunden.
Also ich bin halt so 6, 7 Tage dann immer dran.
Und von morgens bis abends. Das ist schon viel.
Stefan ist volles Tier.
Aber das ist okay. Ich glaube, mit meiner Frau habe ich mich ganz gut arrangiert.
Und wir haben halt keine Kinder. Und dann lässt sich das für den Moment, glaube ich, ganz gut machen. Ist das auch, das ist eine total doofe Frage, weil die Antwort so offen sich ist. Aber ist es auch ein Vorteil, dieses im kleinen Team und in so einem Saftladen-Kollektiv zu arbeiten, dass man dann, also vielleicht nicht weniger arbeitet, aber freier daran ist, sich das einzuteilen?
Absolut.
Oder arbeitet man dann so viel, dass es eh egal ist?
Und also unbedingt, ich finde das, ich genieße das so dermaßen im Vergleich zum Angestellten da sein, dass ich mir die Zeit selber einteilen kann.
Dass man einfach arbeitet, so wie es Sinn macht einfach.
Und dass ich sagen kann, ja genau, es kommt halt mal vor, kommt durchaus mal vor, dass ich irgendwie, okay es ist jetzt ein Sonntag, aber die Frau mit dem Kind ist weg. Und ich habe meine Ruhe und ich bin zu Hause und ich habe voll, ich merke so, okay, jetzt habe ich eine geile Idee und jetzt setze ich mich hin und dann schreibe ich irgendwie den ganzen Tag Kram oder arbeite was am Spiel. Und dann nehme ich mir aber halt den Montag oder irgendwie einen Tag frei, weil ich merke so, hey, Papa hat keinen Bock und das läuft nicht und so. Und das ist, das ist fantastisch.
Oder man setzt sich auch noch mal abends hin. Oder man geht zum Beispiel früher nach Hause, um noch mal den Nachmittagabend mit seiner Familie zu verbringen. Und wenn dann alle im Bett sind, dann kann man sich noch mal abends hinsetzen zwischen acht und elf oder so und auch noch mal was reisen. Also man einfach dieses Flexible selber bestimmen, wie und wann und wo ich arbeite. Das ist super befreiend.
Jetzt haben wir, das ist so geil, ich habe mir am Anfang Sorge gemacht, dass wir irgendwie zwei Stunden nicht voll kriegen. Jetzt haben wir einen Themenblock noch gar nicht angeschnitten. Also der taucht aber so ein bisschen durch. Also Spiele machen ist mehr als nur Spiele machen. Also zum Beispiel kann man als Dozent anscheinend auch arbeiten. Es gibt diese Talk-and-Play-Reihe. Ihr macht im Saftladen dieses, dass man sich regelmäßig trifft und auch mal spricht und redet. Es entstehen zusammen Dinge. Aber bei Maschinen meint, ihr hattet in den letzten, ich weiß nicht, Jahren, letztes Jahr oder zwei Jahren mit dem Goethe-Institut zusammengearbeitet. Was genau war das? Und ist das so ein einmaliges Ding gewesen? Oder ist das auch Spiele machen?
Okay, das sind jetzt verschiedene Fragen. Also kurz erklärend, mit dem Goethe-Institut haben wir zusammengearbeitet für 15 Monate lang. Haben wir eine Kooperation gemacht. Und zwar sind wir gemeinsam mit dem Goethe-Institut in acht unterschiedliche Länder der Welt gereist. Zum Beispiel waren wir in Mexiko City, wir waren in Südkorea, wir waren in Boston, wir waren in Novosibirsk, Russland, Sao Paulo. Und haben dort vor Ort mit Menschen, nicht nur Entwicklern, sondern einfach nur Menschen, ein Game Jam organisiert. Ein Game Jam ist ganz kurz, meistens im begrenzten Zeitrahmen abgesteckt. Es kommen fremde Menschen zusammen. Und die entwickeln innerhalb von einem sehr kurzen Zeitraum ein Spiel, was man spielen kann. Was fertig ist sozusagen, was man rausgeben kann in die Welt und was eigentlich von Leuten einfach konsumiert werden kann. Das haben wir da gemacht. Die Spiele hatten alle das Thema, dass die Menschen vor Ort versuchen sollten, ihre politischen Realität da einfließen zu lassen oder irgendwelche Ideen oder Ansätze, die für sie politisch schienen, in diese Spiele reinzubringen. Also sprich, es waren nicht unbedingt Serious Games im Sinne von, die waren total langweilig und dröge. Es waren auch schon lustige und unterhaltsame Spiele, aber die hatten alle irgendwo eine Komponente, die mehr war als nur, haha, ist lustig zum Spielen. Genau, das haben wir zusammen mit dem Goethe-Institut gemacht. Das Goethe-Institut hat zusammen mit dem Auswärtigen Amt sozusagen die Finanzierung gestemmt und hat die Logistik gemacht, hat vor Ort die Locations ausgewählt und uns mit der Einladung der Partizipierten geholfen. Und Maschinenmensch hat das Know-how reingebracht, was Spiele machen anging und auch die Organisation Game Jam. Wie läuft das ab? Was gibt es da für Sachen, die man zu beachten muss? Und auch währenddessen das Mentoring der Leute, um ihnen zu helfen, diese Spiele zu bauen. Genau, das haben wir so gemacht. Und das war auch Spiele machen, ja.
Aber dahinter steckt da so dieses, ich mache also nicht mein eigenes Spiel, sondern ich benutze die Werkzeuge, die ich durchs Spiele machen gelernt habe, um damit was zu transportieren. Also in dem Fall, um politischem Erleben Ausdruck zu verdienen. Man kann sich auch vorstellen, dass man das in der Pädagogik nutzt und sagt, ich mache Spiele machen mit Menschen zusammen. Man kann sich auch überlegen, vielleicht kann man auch Selbsterfahrungsgruppen gründen, die beim Spiele machen Dinge aufarbeiten. Ist das für euch, blutet das sozusagen ins Leben aus? Und vielleicht auch ins Berufsleben? Und man kann damit mehr machen als nur Spiele machen? Oder ist das eher die Ausnahme, weil sowas immer so aufwendig ist, dass es dann auch finanziert werden muss?
Nö, kann man auf jeden Fall nutzen. Also Spiele homogenisieren ja total gut. Weil die Leute, die sich damit befassen und die das cool finden, die haben auf jeden Fall so einen Common Base. Einerseits sprechen die oft Englisch. Dann haben die alle wahrscheinlich so die Geschichten, wie wir uns jetzt am Anfang vorgestellt haben. So in meiner Kindheit habe ich das und das gemacht und so. Da hat man automatisch schon Themen, über die man sprechen kann. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen dieses Game Jam spezifische. Das ist eine sehr persönliche, intime Erfahrung, die man dadurch lebt. Weil im Falle von der Art Games Reihe, was wir mit dem Goethe-Institut gemacht haben, waren das 48 Stunden hatten die Zeit. Und die haben diese Zeit sehr effektiv nutzen wollen. Da baut sich sofort ein sehr starkes Engagement auf. Die haben auch wenig geschlafen. Die haben dann sozusagen gecruncht währenddessen, um das Bestmögliche zu erreichen. Und das zusammen mit Fremden. Da haben sich dann Gruppen getroffen, zusammengefunden vor Ort. Es war so im Schnitt so zwischen 50 und 80 Partizipienten, teilweise sogar über 120 Leute. Und die finden sich dann so im Schnitt meistens in Fünfergruppen zusammen. Und oft kennen die sich gar nicht vorher. Und die müssen sich alle einigen, die müssen Kompromisse eingehen, um ein Spiel zu verfolgen. Die müssen alle am gleichen Strang ziehen. Teilweise stehen die unter großem Stress, weil jeder will das Beste für das Spiel haben. Teilweise stehen die unter Schlafentzug auch ein bisschen, sind müde, erschöpft am zweiten, dritten Tag. Also da wird es sehr schnell sehr intim und eng.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dem war, aber bei Game Jams lese ich ab und zu, ihr könnt vorbeikommen, auch wenn ihr gar keine Ahnung vom Coden und Spielemacher habt, ist das wirklich so?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Jeder kann da irgendwie was beitragen. Also selbst wenn ich überhaupt nichts kann, kann ich immer noch das Spiel spielen, ich kann den Leuten helfen, indem ich irgendwas organisiere, gucke, dass ich die Kommunikation unter den Menschen verbessere. Da findet jeder, kann ja irgendwas. Und da findet jeder auch seine Rolle, wenn man da hingeht. Also ich glaube, es wird leider viel zu wenig genutzt. Also die Leute haben immer so Hemmungen, dann hinzugeben.
Aber jeder, der da mitmacht, der würde sich freuen über einfach andere Leute, die wieder andere Ideen mit einbringen. Weil wir dann wirklich bald zu Ende sind, würde ich jetzt gerne noch ein paar Sachen einsammeln, falls man jetzt in die Sendung gehört, dann sehr schnell so, man, das klingt ja ganz cool, ich würde da vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher rein stoppern. Also was man jetzt machen kann, was schon gesagt wurde, ich kann tatsächlich nicht trauen, zu einem Game Jam zu gehen. Habt ihr jetzt bestätigt zumindest. Es gibt diese Talk and Play Reihe, die ist wann? Alle?
Alle zwei Monate.
Alle zwei Monate auf berlingamescene.com gehen. Da gibt es einen Kalender, unter anderem auch ein Reiter extra für das Talk and Play, berlingamescene.com.
Es gibt einmal im Jahr die Amaze, die ist immer im späten April. Im April, also wenn Berlin Games Week ist.
BerlinMinigameJam auch.
Was ist das?
Das ist einmal im Monat ein 8-Stunden-Gamejam, der stattfindet. Der ist im Koop, beim Komposator. Ich glaube, die URL ist BerlinGameJam.de oder BerlinMinigameJam.de.
Ist aber auch auf BerlinGameScene.
Ja, genau.
Findet man auch.
Und wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen konkreter, wenn ich denke, ich will mich mit Spielentwicklung beschäftigen, was ist die erste Stelle, wo der sagt, oder meinetwegen auch nur der Google-Suchbegriff, den ich eingeben muss, oder Suchmaschine eurer Wahl, womit fange ich an? Du hast es vorhin schon gesagt, Unity kann man anfangen. Wird es mit dem Kopf schwer, so, ist das das richtige?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also Unity finde ich schon ganz schön oben eingestiegen. Also ich würde eher wahrscheinlich mit Smodding reingehen. Also überhaupt erst mal anfangen sozusagen, weil manchmal ist ja...
Also ist es wichtiger, etwas zu machen, wo ich schnell was sehen kann, als mir was Komplexes rauszusuchen, was ich erst mal lerne?
Das kommt auf dich persönlich an.
Okay, aber es gibt diese beiden Wege sozusagen.
Ich würde zumindest sagen, Unity nenne ich einfach mal, weil es so viel Material dazu gibt, weil es auch so viele qualitative YouTube-Videos dafür gibt.
Also könnte man sagen, wenn ich vielleicht von Programmieren eh schon Ahnung habe, dann kann ich damit vielleicht gut einsteigen. Wenn ich sozusagen eher, wie ihr euch so ein bisschen vorhin angefällt, ja, also Coden, hm, nun kann ich ja nicht so. Dann kann ich sozusagen eher mir ein bestehendes Spiel suchen, was Modding kommt. Also es gibt ja Spiele, die Level-Editoren mitbringen.
Zum Beispiel, oder es gibt ganze Spiele, wo es mit nichts anderes geht. Minecraft, Kreativmodus. Mario Maker, sowas. Und einfach, also ich denke, es ist gar nicht so anders als hacken. Was ist einfach, man muss von dem passiven, ich konsumiere, was mir vorgesetzt wird, wechseln auf die Seite, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt mach ich selber mal was. Und was auch, ja, also ein Zugang wäre, also Unity ist sicher ein Tool, es ist eine Game Engine und das ist sicher ein Tool, das wahnsinnig gut dokumentiert ist. Und das ist halt erstmal kostenlos, aber es ist nicht, also es hat schon auch trotzdem eine große Einstiegshürde, würde ich sagen, weil man relativ schnell zumindest einigermaßen programmieren können sollte oder es lernen muss.
Was ist, was sind bei der Spielentwicklung der für euch der häufigste Frustrationspunkt oder Dinge, die euch frustrieren und wie überwindet ihr die? Spielentwicklung ist so toll, es gibt nie Frustrationspunkte.
Es dauert immer alles so lange. Es dauert alles immer länger. Du hast die coole Idee, du kannst es umsetzen. Es läuft nicht mal schlecht, aber es dauert einfach länger. Und dann ist einfach keine Zeit mehr da. Das ist eigentlich das Problem.
Meistens, wenn es richtig losgeht, dann muss man eigentlich fertig sein.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich frustrierend, wenn man Dinge, die man gerne noch gemacht hätte, nicht tun kann, weil die Zeit weg ist.
Ich habe jetzt noch zum Schluss die Gretchenfrage. Wenn man euch so zuhört, dann habe ich den Eindruck gewonnen, wenn ich wirklich selber Spiele machen will, im Sinne von, ich möchte auch in einer handwerklichen, selbst erfahrenen Art ein Spiel auf die Welt bringen, dann muss ich das so machen wie ihr, also in einem kleinen Team mindestens. Und darf auf gar keinen Fall eine große Firma geben, weil da ist es eher ein Job. Ist das so oder ist das nur so ein Eindruck, den ich jetzt habe und eigentlich ist das alles ganz anders?
Also das kommt ein bisschen auf die Firma und das Projekt an, ich denke, und vielleicht auch manchmal auf den Zeitraum. Also ich habe schon auch, ich habe ja das Beispiel bei Jäger, hatte ich schon das Gefühl, dass ich ans Back of the Line auch handwerklich mitgearbeitet habe und auch was zu dem Spiel beigetragen habe, obwohl das am Ende 120 Leute waren. Aber und gleichzeitig ist eben der große Vorteil, den der große Studio hat und gerade am Anfang hat, muss man auch ganz klar sagen, ist, dass man erstens bezahlt wird und zweitens, ja wirklich, und zweitens Dinge lernt. Dass da ganz viele andere Leute sind, die total gut sind, die viel besser sind als man selber und von denen man lernen kann. Und das würde ich nicht von der Hand weisen, aber für mich persönlich ist jetzt dieses im kleinen Team arbeiten sehr erfüllend.
Du hast halt auch schon viel Erfahrung mitgebracht, ne? Ich sehe immer wieder junge Leute, die dann sozusagen direkt ohne den Einstieg in eine Spielfirma unabhängig werden und die rennen halt teilweise in so offensichtliche Wände rein, wo man so im Nachhinein denkt zum Menschen. Ja, für uns offensichtlich. Weil wir halt einfach schon Erfahrung gesammelt haben. Deswegen, ich weiß auch nie genau, was ich den Leuten raten soll. Zuerst in ein großes Studio oder ein mittelgroßes Studio, geht bloß nicht in so ein riesengroßes Studio am Anfang. Also bei Ubisoft oder so was würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt, weiß nicht genau. Vielleicht ist da auch cool, da kann man sich super spezialisieren. Aber ich weiß nicht, was ich raten würde. Weil manchmal verliert man auch so ein bisschen die Edge, also dieses Anarchistische, was so junge Leute manchmal haben und dann so Spiele wie Hotline Miami entstehen oder so was. Das geht auch verloren, wenn man zu lange auf einem gemütlichen Stuhl sitzt.
Ich hätte mir jetzt so eine schwarz-weiße Antwort gewünscht. Ihr müsstet ja wieder differenzieren. Weil jetzt die Zeit wirklich rum ist, werde ich nicht mehr fragen, was eure einzelnen nächsten Projekte oder möglicherweise Deadlines sind, sondern es gab neulich, hattet ihr so eine offene Veranstaltung, da konnte man von euch allen und auch von den anderen mal mit Saftladen sehen, an was ihr gerade arbeitet und das sogar ausprobieren. Wann ist die nächste dieser Art?
Bestimmt zur nächsten großen Veranstaltung in Berlin. Versuchen wir jetzt eigentlich immer das zu machen, also mindestens zu Amaze oder zu Gamesweek, die jetzt aber schon dieses Jahr war. Ansonsten würde mir jetzt spontan keins einfallen.
Aber wir haben die Website saftladen.berlin und da gibt es auch ein Newsletter.
Genau, abonniert den Newsletter.
Alles klar, sehr schön. Dann vielen Dank, der Servat, Jörg Friedrich, Stefan Höfelbrink und Johannes Christmann.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Alle vom Saftladen. Vielen Dank, liebes Publikum, dass ihr doch noch in die erste Reihe gekommen seid. Ja, das war's für heute. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe noch eine kleine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.